hat mein name ist sogar herzlich
willkommen wie heute 10 2 geboxt
ich habe hier in diesem wunderschönen
und beutel einige gegenstände
vorbereitet so um die zehn stück max
dort in seinem buch sax zählen
gegenstände vorbereitet die wir uns
jetzt gegenseitig hier die box eingeben
werden und dann packen wir quasi unsere
hände hierdurch müssen dann in der box
die das jeweils andere eigene erraten
wer genau wir fangen jetzt an meine
erste sache für dich max werde ich jetzt
hier unten rein packen sie liegt dort
drin und jetzt meine damen und herren
max darf jetzt rein passt du bist so
eine miese so dass du mir locker
irgendwie auch ein messer oder
reißzwecken oder sowas reinlegen kurz
was für welche hertha wird apple i pods
fürs iphone 7 welche also direkt herab
läuft geht auf jeden fall am markt haben
wir mal was wir hier feiern werde ich
erstmal die augen zumachen lieber
dadurch fühlen für das jetzt fühlen also
ich darf jetzt auch augen auch werden
klingt das
ich weiß was das ist das ist dingen
kommt ja gucken sie den korkenzieher
nächstes einloggen doch nicht dass ich
da nicht doch nicht bewegt sich irgendwo
halte ok jetzt ist hiergegen dieser
mädchen
der coach will es gibt ja einfach scheiß
kopf du jung bist du so einen scheiß
hier mal wieder ist es um fleischklopfer
holen konnten ein bisschen nachschauen
ich würde sagen die sind korkenzieher es
ist eine knoblauchpresse alter wenn ich
im leben nicht aufgekommen könnte das
auch nicht sagen wenn ich das jetzt
sehen würde dass seine ist jetzt im
januar luca ist natürlich ein bisschen
koch beschränkt hast du schon mal
genutzt nicht also okay es bleibt beim 1
0 für max max die nächste sache die du
es erraten muss augen zu es befindet
sich jetzt in deiner pocsay markt warum
bist du eigentlich so gut darin mag das
schon auf seinem kanal gemacht ist mir
einfach nur ein dünnes tuch tipps ist es
wirklich ein ganz normales tun habe es
ist etwas neues suchen schauen wir das
ist ein ganz tolles buch meine damen und
herren 20 vermag es nicht gehen aber
glaub ich etwas weiter vorne kann sie
auch nach öffnen und anfangen zu rate
ich habe angst sagt er ich hab mich ein
pdf rtf
ist es das was die katze kratzt genau
genommen
vielleicht kennst du die deswegen auch
schon wieder nicht weil es mir ein
bisschen beunruhigen würde was für
material ist es der raum das ist dann
wie unterwäsche so ein trubel ball oder
irgendwie sowas oder so gummibänder ich
hab dachte es deswegen gummibänder dabei
sind das für gummi bender aneinander in
so einem ball aber jegliches gefühl ja
und man sich doch nicht ab dass sich
auch schon probiert also ich würde sagen
das ist eine truppe war womit du dich in
der wüste schrubben kannst und ich
schaue jetzt nach und das ist jetzt
kommen die ich meine schwierigen sachen
erst und zwar max augen
dahinter von augenauf hände rein und los
gehts jetzt beginnt nämlich das
schwierige meine damen und herren darf
man nicht einen stahlschrank kenne ich
jetzt so keine kondome also ich greife
jetzt mal hier rein und schaue was das
ist so ein ich weiß nicht was es ist es
ist sonnig weiß nicht ob die farbe
wirklich ist aber ich kenne das nur als
gelbe bälle man somit in die badewanne
nimmt oder mit dem die dusche oder
irgendwas oder vielleicht doch in
gymnastik beim sport beim heute eher
gelb sein du kannst eine farbe erfüllen
ich kann fahren finde ich schwöre das
geld ist laut eine massage ja massage
jim ab und der flugverkehr glück hast du
auch mal ein punkt so ein steht es jetzt
freuen und jetzt meine damen und herren
kommen wir wirklich zu einer sache hier
denke ich nie
hier dass die sagte ich lege essen hier
unten max hände rein und los geht's
jetzt verfällt oben so ein ding zum
aufhängen was hat also sagt da die
meisten verpackungen vorzugehen
aber musik zu dir sowas ja es ist ja ihr
seid die zähne aufgefunden ehrlich ja
welche cd bist du dich verhalten gebe
aber was habe ich denn hier einfach nur
einfach nur klassik also ich da alles
getroffen jetzt müssen leichter dass die
nächste sache kann definitiv kennen kann
ich kenne es ist ein
ich weiß es sagte scott leichtes
anschwitzen
also leute die nächste sache meine damen
und herren ist das hier ich werde es nun
unten in die woche hat die stadt jetzt
mein kopf kommt wenn du nicht draußen
das ist dann das ist schon krass also
geldschein
es ist ein geldschein ja aber was
vereine 400 euro 5 er glaube ich nicht
dafür zu kuren diese scheiße handy ja
seit ich mein handy in der kamera und es
klingelt nicht fest wie wir zu früh
aufzustehen uns doch bloß zumal das ist
quality content freunde dafür kriegt man
schon mal videopreis hin und wieder
runter fünfziger und ich würde sagen
übernimmt fünf aber es ist 10 sa 25
sätzen erhalten kein bruder weil du
denkst hier ruder gib mir den weil du
dich mit den jetzt schon ganz oben zu
haben
was ist da ich würde zu beginn sagen das
ist ein kühlkissen ills ich würde sagen
es sind schulklassen die sache ist
allerdings fühlt sich schon sehr sehr
lang aber wenn das wirklich von dem mit
genommen hast du bist ja entweder das
ist eine wärmflasche und wärmekissen
kühlkissen wird sagen
während der kühlkissen ist beides wir
sagen 730 das klingt ich muss wirklich
sagen der ist diesmal wirklich wirklich
schwierig also ich habe allen gesagt die
sind alle schwierig aber diesmal wenn du
das jetzt erlebt weil der damen und
herren das wäre schon krank man sollte
ja elf zu 503 todesangst
nein du [ __ ] cuttermesser alter eher
was macht zu stellen als vorher ich
hätte jetzt irgendwie so gemacht hat mir
das so folgen so gesagt nicht vor
sichtbar wenn man sagt vorsicht damit es
dann geht es klar oder das war ein
fucking messer machen max ich habe die
ganze zeit gesagt und du heute konnte
sie sagen immer noch erraten aber
diesmal ist es wirklich etwas augen zu
lassen
das ist wirklich etwas wo ich sagen muss
dass er rät du niemals ich packe ist
jetzt einfach mal hier unten rein und
die live meine damen und herren max eine
benutzte sagte barig malta bestimmt
bibel sondern ist wieder okay also
diesmal ganz vorsichtig ganz vorsichtig
ist einfach es ist eine ganz alte okay
war zwar da hat sich was bewegt da hat
sich das war wirklich eng bevor es raus
wenn du deine ich hoffe dass ich hasse
das wenn man nicht weiß was man anfassen
was ist hat das soll das sein dass
deswegen so ein gummi teil mit so ein
stern mit gummi aus gummi keine ahnung
okay okay was ist das wie apples und
überraschungspaket dieser über das
beschreiben jetzt kommen wir wirklich zu
einer sache wo ich sagen würde dass der
ist niemals wirklich ich habe es jetzt
reingeschmissen und jetzt greift ein
wenn du das hinkriegt muss ich sagen
dann bist du auf jeden fall sehr gut was
ist wirklich wirklich das erste wo ich
mir wirklich
das habe ich nehmen wir das objekt kann
das eigentlich nicht erraten kennst es
wenn du siehst aber du kannst es glaube
ich nicht erraten also ich glaube du
wirst jetzt nicht aufkommen bei alle
anderen sachen die ich bisher gezeigt
habe irgendwie so eine socke oder
zahnseide da kommt man relativ gebiete
auf aber das ist eigentlich schon ein
bisschen komplizierter ist das ist das
aber ein bestandteil von etwas größerem
ja super finde ich absolut okay das
kannst du auf dem iphone
darauf setzen dass eine größere linse
beste schiedsrichter das schlechteste
was zu halten war geschäftsmann ist
schon von meinem schrecken gerade bitte
und der stelle würde ich wirklich sagen
max ich habe jetzt das letzte die
letzten gegenständlichen iran geben für
max gibis seinen gegenstand
es ist ein seiten das vitamin tabletten
wie soll ich da drauf kommen ich hab
sogar noch drei letzten sachen es mir
gerade aufgefallen habe ich entscheide
mich jetzt und zwar ist dieser letzte
punkt hier sehr sehr entscheidend meine
damen und herren weil es ist der letzte
punkt oder das gerät liegt jetzt hier
drin ich glaube du gerätst bevor die
hände reibt sich laut das relativ
schnell aber es ist etwas besonderes das
eigentlich schon mal also es ist auch
gefährlich
also das kann zum tod führen
schraubenzieher nicht gerne hasen
prüfung ja phasen prüfer kann ich zum
tod führen da wenn du nicht benutzt kann
zum tod finden dann machst du das alles
entscheidende item gewonnen hat kann ich
jetzt nur noch gleich meine damen und
herren vorsicht also ja das ist auf
jeden fall was für die dusche das
infektionsgeschehen man meinen letzten
gegenstand bist du ein problem wenn ich
den rasen komplett gewonnener müsst ihr
eine zelle verlassen das drin das ist
für alle zimmer lampe immer wenn man sie
mag es gab ja diese scheiss licht etwas
macht
okay ich hab jetzt bald erraten das
heißt weil ich habe diese challenge
jetzt gewonnen
[Musik]
nein dort laster menschen nicht gesehen
ziemlich abstoßend das was ihr vom video
das was jetzt hier vom video ihr könnt
jetzt hier mal den kanal abonnieren oder
hier unten mal einen job ausschenken ihr
findet ihr zwei andere videos und wenn
ich schon abonnent zeit könnt ihr auch
die glocke klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]